welcome to uh wasm plus kubernetes
Beyond containers we're going to talk a
little bit about how we can kind of
Leverage some of these Technologies
together to build a working solution to
build web assembly services on the back
end that are real and running uh and
solve some business problems along the
way my name is Sean Isom I am a senior
manager at Adobe working on optimizing
our Cloud infrastructure and this is
Colin
Colin's also a senior engineer at Adobe
working on some of our new webassembly
based stack yeah
web services yes
okay so I always like to start with a
quote or a thesis statement
um here's a somewhat provocative one
people don't really want Innovation this
is a quote from Justin Etheridge people
talk about Innovation a whole lot but
what they are real usually looking for
is cheap wins and Novelty if you truly
innovate and change the way that people
have to do things expect mostly negative
feedback if you believe in what you're
doing and know it will really improve
things then brace yourself for a long
battle show of hands in the room who can
who can empathize with this in this room
I'm sure we've all been here with
Technologies before so you know I think
you know still want to keep this to be a
very positive talk but a lot of this is
going to be some of the lessons we've
learned along along the way getting into
the state we're in today where we can
kind of get some of these Technologies
in our operating wasm is the tool I I
personally believe it is the tool to
write better software faster but the
innovating is is hard especially in a
large Enterprise organization
uh so we'll just talk briefly you know
I'm going to start with a little bit of
History container I don't want to bore
you too much with some of our background
on kubernetes this is wasm day not
kubernetes day right now but uh
understand a little bit of the history
you know some of our current setup uh
how we're thinking about this some of
the business problems we're going to
solve Colin's gonna have a pretty
awesome demo of some of the stuff
working in production uh and then you
know summering summarizing why we think
this is worth it
history so all right so what do we mean
when we mean running things in the cloud
uh obviously a lot of us probably
remember pre-container days uh VM backed
Services
um these are the the the dark days
um before containers magically fixed
everything for us
um there's a group at Adobe is a startup
that they actually acquired called
behance uh that was really focused on
solving a couple of different problems
first was cicd
um this is something that other people
can probably empathize as well but build
Knights right trying to move all that
code out to production trying to get all
these systems working together that's a
challenging task and so uh you know kind
of standardizing around this is early
late 2014 early 2015 standardizing
around a CI CD framework that could be
used to help automate and solve some of
those pain points and then deploying
Apache mesos to run containers uh first
as like systemd units I don't know if
anyone remembers those days but uh you
know that's uh you know that was kind of
the leading way I'd say this is a little
bit for I think ECS was even released so
this this is the the bad old days of
containers
um
why why do we do this right so if you
think about a developer as an adobe
developer but again a lot of you can
probably empathize with this as well
um what are the things that a developer
has to think about there's a lot of
different things and that landscape is
changing all over the time with
Technologies and you know really like
this causes problems when you're trying
to do things in a large organization do
you want you know 20 30 50 100 different
teams different orgs different GEOS
Reinventing the wheel all over time I
don't think so and so thus in 2015 ethos
was born late late 2015 early 2016. and
so the idea behind the ethos project was
can we run multi-tenant web services at
Adobe like can we magically get all
these different service teams
interoperating putting their stuff
together containers was the tool of
choice based off of mesos based off RC
CI CD framework uh and you know kind of
automagically scale you know get those
get the cost efficiency from the the
economies of scale running those
together so
um you know running misos manually is
hard we standardize around DC dcos 2017
migrated everything over to that
um you know dcos was a great platform
for us for for uh many years but there's
a lot of things we had to build
ourselves that did not come out of the
box and uh you know obviously you see
the direction the community has gone so
starting late 2018
early 2019 we started uh building around
retooling the entire platform around
kubernetes when we think about web
services there's kind of three different
models that exist in kubernetes there's
ethos Kaz which container as a service
and this is kind of where we took that
pave path for for gcos and we replicated
that experience in kubernetes but
obviously infrastructure is code with
you know the vast amount of kubernetes
experience the community has we built
this new pass-based system too where you
can provision namespace on a cluster and
you know get some basic Network policies
and get right access in that namespace
and hook up your own CI CD tool or do
whatever you want deploy your own
infrastructure in there and then fairly
new is using Argo and Helm the product
called Flex which is how we can kind of
get the best of both worlds where we can
give you a CEI CD Suite to actually give
you right access as well so you can
create your own cloud native resources
um ethos is a huge project Powers I
would say at this point most of adobe's
web services uh over 5000 Production
Services lots of containers lots of CPUs
um this is kind of interesting this is
going to be a central theme of this talk
is this concept of multi-tenancy right
and so you talk to a lot of other large
companies uh you know there's 500
clusters a thousand clusters there's an
infinite number of kubernetes clusters
that are running this is scaled up a lot
in the last uh you know year or so I
would say like we this account was under
100 for a while because of our
multi-tenancy that has scaled out but
we're still at 285 clusters running you
know those kinds of Statistics so I
think that's pretty notable
uh where where so along that Journey
where has that gotten us today
um I'd say our kubernetes has been very
successful given those numbers uh we
still have you know kind of that unified
SRE operations model we have a security
model that other teams have to onboard
to by default uh we are still mostly a
12-factor app-based system mostly a
multi-tenant system as that cluster
count has gotten larger I would say that
over time we have uh you know pivoted a
little a little bit away from that um
you know for specific larger workloads
but the idea is that you know we can
provide this basic platform for hosting
Services we can be Cloud agnostic we can
be platform agnostic we can run
containers as a service we can run I
mean streaming workloads anything you
can name and essentially provide this
infrastructure as a service was it an
additional set of value-add components
on top of it
okay so again this is wasm day let's
start talking about what wasm can do for
us so uh as we look to how multi-tenancy
Works in kubernetes today uh it is
operationally very simple allows us to
get you know uh economies of scale with
our people with our cluster operations
um This Promise of you know just make
everything multi-tenant you've got large
applications you've got small
applications they're just going to fill
up all the space automatically and get
rid of all of your overhead that's not
really the case it's very efficient in
theory but you know when you start
mixing applications different
architectures different scheduling
constraints different taints and
tolerations different Zone affinities uh
you know minimum replica counts that are
more than the nodes in the cluster you
can imagine how over time things scale
out and things the efficiency level
drops
um so you know I'm not here to convince
you that you should get rid of
kubernetes obviously a lot of people are
running kubernetes but when you have run
this kind of multi-tenant setup while
it's operationally very excellent it can
be very expensive to run and so when
we're looking at what's now text and for
for us today that's webassembly uh you
know we want to be able to leverage our
existing investment in kubernetes we've
got a lot of it we know how to work with
it we've got all these different other
resources that you know these hundreds
to thousands of teams within Adobe have
built for these thousands to tens of
thousands of services that are already
operating in Cooper day so we need a
model where we can still leverage that
investment be but be able to integrate
in uh what's new so kind of the question
is what if there's a better way can we
make some of these things work together
using webassembly and so uh you know how
I'm personally thinking about this is a
model more towards fast I would not say
pure fast but uh and actually let's go
to the next slide there's a lot of
services that are running on our
platform uh that look kind of like this
you know we it's a like I said multi-tem
platform lots of different types of
services but the standard service if I
was to Define what a service looks like
it's probably written in Java spring
brute using a lot of internal libraries
to pull some utilization statistics
about 28 CPU utilization about 55 Ram
utilization so that's good but not great
right and so what that really means is
that like we've got a large Java service
that's serving web traffic and it's
going to take incoming requests and
crunch some numbers on them and then
maybe like fire off a call at an
external dependency pull some data from
a database wait for that other external
dependency to do something and then you
know with that transform data send it
back to the user maybe you know
asynchronously go store that you know
send that to another service store in
another data system and it's kind of
like data processing flow I would say is
is a very standard workflow that's
replicated across hundreds if not
thousands of services and so if you look
at a compute profile of those Services
right like we're as strong as our
weakest link which for this one
might have pulled the wrong example but
uh the idea often that is CPU right or
memory bound we're iops bound we've got
some other constraining component and
there's just idling CPU there uh that we
would like to be able to do something
with
so uh
how could webassembly be the answer to
this then
um let's give a bit of background on how
webassembly at Adobe has historically
worked we have a lot of experience with
this on the browser side and actually
predating webassembly uh if anybody
remembers portable native client from
Google azim.js you know kind of
predecessors of webassembly these are
all things that have been integrated
into Adobe products over the last 10
years starting with the Lightroom web
beta all the way to the production
version acrobat web moving towards the
you know our Flagship experience of
Photoshop which has been running in beta
and browser for almost a year now
um and some Next Generation products
where wasm's really a key enabler in
allowing us to to build that rich client
experience in a web browser so we have
all this experience working with
webassembly code already mostly you know
taking native code mostly interoperating
interoperating with JavaScript but uh
it's something that that you know we
have the experience to leverage in other
places because it meets all these same
requirements that we're looking for the
back end it's a very high performance
system it is uh secure by default for
example right we don't have to worry
about multi-sent isolation
so
this is the experiment how do we
actually run this in kubernetes and so
we're utilizing wasm Cloud right now uh
uh you see on the left here this is kind
of a legacy setup I would say this is uh
and there's some links there and you
know I'll send out the slides and
everything but if you take the cosmonic
kubernetes of plier this is a script
that allows you to kind of bootstrap a
wasmcloud installation within a cluster
we started by doing this within a
namespace and so this is within the
context of a client application and
that's important because namespaces are
isolated from each other right like when
a client service onboards to our system
and we run a multi-tenant system if they
need to VPC appear back to one of their
own cloud resources they get a net poll
that allows their namespace and only
their namespace to talk to that inside a
multi-tenant cluster and so this was a
nice way of kind of like keeping that
you know namespace boundary isolation
for external resources but as you can
imagine this probably didn't hit our
efficiency goals as much as we would
like because we're replicating that core
laws and Cloud infrastructure for every
single app that needs to work this way
and so what we're moving towards is this
more multi-tenant model this is
utilizing some very hot off the press
Scripts some coming out of the Wasa Mayo
Workshop that the cosmotic folks did but
essentially the idea here which is this
diagram on the right is that within the
namespace boundary which is are these
blue boxes we've got uh we've got the
automation provision Services allow us
to get Ingress to talk to a webassembly
module we've got uh walls and Cloud
providers running the back end these can
be like HTTP providers that are serving
as HTTP traffic and then they
communicate through Nats you know over
this lattice this green box back to a
pool of common wasm Cloud hosts and so
with that we have core compute capacity
that's provisioned to just do work and
do work in a fast kind of way and so we
uh it's very efficient we can run all
these different workloads side by side
because they're secure by default we can
run the actual execution of that code
outside the namespace boundary and then
just communicating back and forth back
up to providers that are running in
namespace uh you know using a Nats topic
which is secured by default as well in
order to then communicate with those
external dependencies so let's this it's
it's kind of you know the Best of Both
Worlds if there is a Best of Both Worlds
to be had between kubernetes and
webassembly because we can have other
things that are still running that
namespace that we need to talk to that
we can access we can talk to all these
external providers but we're still able
to drive down that CPU cost by those
greater economies of scale by actually
isolating out the core client compute
not having those Services just spending
all of their time idling
um a lot of this is going to involve
getting code working for webassembly in
the first place and taking a service and
building it for webassembly so Colin has
a awesome amount of experience in demo
here that he's going to show you yep
thanks Sean so um yeah I I have to
preface this whole thing because I
didn't do this last time for you who are
in Valencia remember you might remember
I gave a talk last year so I'm going to
preface this with I'm going to read it
okay
um
my goal is not to make any sort of
criticism or indictment of decisions
that have been made this technology has
a very bright future everyone involved
should be very proud of what they've
accomplished I'm just trying to
highlight the work that still needs to
be done in the next phase of focusing on
developer experience Okay so
afterwards okay if if uh I don't mean to
offend
um so this is you know we've already hit
a lot of these highlights this is this
Bailey uh this is from her YouTube video
with Luke Wagner so a lot of work great
work's been done and uh and it's really
it's really great it's been great to
witness
um
so uh last year it was background
removal it was a really simple service I
think the hardest part for me was taking
a spring boot app and learning rust
um so that was that was the hardest part
there it just worked really flawlessly
and the reason was that it had very few
dependencies so
um I would I could take a signature and
I would I could remove the background
and I think I ran it on maybe fastly and
cloudflare was in cloud and fermion spin
worked great
um this year
is the content authenticity proxy
so uh here we have the the Holy Father
valenciaga so right this is a very
timely thing and adobe's really made a
big investment in AI Generation
Um so this kind of thing so is this a
real image was it was it AI generated
was it modified in Photoshop that kind
of thing
um
okay so it sounds simple right I'm gonna
I'm gonna I have a proxy this is meant
to be running kind of on the on the edge
close to the users so CDN Edge think of
that kind of thing
um what we call CDN Edge compute right
user will pass a URL to the service the
service will download it check it it
will resize the image now there's a
cache maybe it's been cached uh
transcode it so make resize it uh record
that in the content authenticity
manifest so this is something adobe's
been working on the content authenticity
initiative that's a embedded data in an
image on the history of that image and
then uh return the image and push the
transcoded image into cache
okay so as I said before last year
worked really well because the only the
only crate that was a dependency really
was image and this year uh very
different okay so uh fast image resize
because this is supposed to be Fast Net
needs Sim D and the fast image resize
crate before I started not support
wasm so there's some simd work the c2pa
SDK needed to work with webassembly Wazi
specifically which required open SSL x05
x509 ring in Chrono so I did what any
uh
foolhardy developer did I forked
everything
um so and the the worst part was when I
when I came to the content authenticity
initiative team they said
um
uh oh it already supports wasm right of
course it it doesn't support wasm it
supports wasm in the browser right and
that's kind of the problem is the wasn't
32 unknown unknown Target which I used
last year for background removal
wasn't going to work because it was
going to pick up wasambind gen and JS
sis and so I had to
go through the cargo got Tamil and
everywhere
that required any of these crates in the
code and do lots of little configs so
you know
as you can see
um so that was that was a that was a
real challenge
um
and actually so I actually did get it
all to compile but the open SSL
not quite there yet so it actually kind
of fell down but this actually this this
highlights
um
kind of a positive thing is that I I got
it working in Wasim Cloud because I
moved that openssl into a provider so
once openssl is ready for um for Wazi
uh it can go into the into the web
assembly boundary
um okay so the simdi which is kind of
the successful part so I led I I lowered
your expectations and now here's the
actual success so um this was what the
real challenge here was getting Wazi CMD
to actually be faster than Wazi or sorry
webassembly not same date right
um
so uh and this is kind of a bigger point
which is webassembly would not be
possible or if it was it would be much
more complicated if CPU architectures
were not so homogenized right
um back maybe back
20 years ago when we still had big
Indian mips or power PC this would be a
different story right if we had to
compile something and maybe it'll run
big ending maybe to run little endian or
or you know take anything else right
there's a real uniformity now in CPU
architecture
um
but the problem is simdi
very very uh you know interesting the
instructions vary greatly between neon
and ssc4 and AVX 512 right so
uh this is the list I took it from the
inscripted docs
um
and I had to avoid these and of course I
didn't have to avoid them in my actual
code I had to avoid them in the
optimized code right so here I have
the most efficient way to write
something
and that was 10 times slower than the
fastest way to do it which is five
commit five instructions versus 12
instructions so I'm pulling out what and
I'm making sure I'm not getting these
very slow shift left shift right
commands right and and those are slow
not just on x86 they're also slow on
neon on arm so that was uh that was very
challenging
[Music]
um
and so I think we've you know we've
really pounded this today
what goes in the wasm Box what doesn't
go in the Watson box and I think there's
some debate on this kind of thing
um
uh you know we I think hopefully you've
been convinced if you were on the fence
that there's an advantage running things
in webassembly today
um
you know so we want things to go in
there
we just if we want to be performant we
don't not everything can kind of go
there so what what I would kind of like
would be cryptography in webassembly
because you know openssl should work on
a very variety of architectures and os's
Cindy maybe not so I kind of in my
example I actually kind of swapped these
um like I would prefer it was the other
way but in my example cmd's inside the
laws in box and cryptography is outside
although cryptography the
um the CMD instructions were ended up
being four times faster so it was you
know it wasn't a complete waste of time
um okay so demo time
all right here we go
so
let's see
okay so it's
nope
yeah okay this is good
sorry
this is always terrifying
um so here we've got Adobe Firefly and I
was like what's a good image because it
doesn't understand webassembly Firefly
you know not in the model web assembly
for the Firefly am I am AI training data
but I was like well crabs and gophers
and Amsterdam right so made some images
I picked one of them
uh
and then uh
I put it
I put it somewhere I put it in GitHub I
tried S3 it didn't work I don't know why
um
and uh it was very slow
and so then
um
here so I
here so this is kind of the output of
the of the wasm cloud and I'm just gonna
so I'm not gonna refresh that
uh but I will curl my way and see if we
can get it
uh
okay so yeah it worked okay and then uh
if we do CPA tools so so that's what it
did it it grabbed the image it
transcoded it and updated its ctpa
manifest
um
sorry
I can't type up here when I'm uh sorry
it's true you really can't type hey tool
um what is going on
sorry
there's
oh all right uh I'll see if I can
hold on
oh c2ba tool
right
tool there we go wow
um transcode so just seeing here we've
got the transcoding action that was done
by the wasm cloud
um
service so so that is the demo and the
whole idea is this is actually going to
hopefully run uh on edge compute and
maybe in wasm cloud or if we can get
that in multiple places
uh yeah so that's that's the demo
um
see if we can get back to PowerPoint
all right handing it back over to Sean
oh sorry actually sorry I have some
notes um
we do use webassembly on the server side
a lot at Adobe but it runs in headless
Chrome in fact including in the projects
I'm working on around
newer web services around Creative Cloud
um so
we have to at least match what we have
in the browser for webassembly with Wazi
or else it's going to be really hard to
convince these people who already think
they know webassembly to move over to
Wazi so
that's it that's that's it and that's
not a criticism okay thanks
okay
well
I don't really have much
I don't really have much more to add but
uh basically I just want to summarize
you know so like this whole journey
we've been on so we've gone to Cloud
native we run kubernetes we run
kubernetes fairly well we've got some
business problems we want to try to
solve webassembly is a tool that helps
us write better software faster but you
know as we've seen you know both on the
how we run it although that experience
is improving how we write it what the
developer experience looks like like
this is hard how do you convince you
know thousands of Java developers that
are used to writing code you know that
is like
vmbase that we've wrapped a Docker
container around that we've put up in
the cloud right like that's the model
how do we convince people essentially to
get that back to a model where it's like
we want to free you from those
infrastructure concerns we want you to
be able to write the software once and
run it anywhere and so
um you know I think we're on that
journey I think we're in kind of like
you know the technology adoption curve
we're into like you know storming phase
of this right now trying to get all this
going but this is worth it right it's
worth it for the efficiency it's worth
it for the performance it will be worth
it for the developer experience wasm
isn't the enabler of all these things
but we just also you know like we're not
going to stop running kubernetes
tomorrow so I Envision a world where
these coexist uh far into the future and
I appreciate all the work that everyone
in the community has been doing to make
all these things reality
that's it thank you
absolutely
hello absolutely fantastic
um definitely love to see it and these
are really challenging problems so it's
cool to see like how y'all actually
tackling them I know y'all have
questions so please uh if you have a
question raise your hand so I can come
give you the mic
all the way in back
here we go
making my way back here just give me a
moment
okay perfect so yeah I was like I don't
have enough time to throw in if you
could please introduce yourself
so Larry carvalo with robust Cloud
um you know we had the days of cloud
first then we went container first if we
are going to Washim first and you said
you know developers there's still some
more time before it becomes easy for
developers what is stopping
the way to make wasm easier for
developers to use
yeah so so great so so the point isn't
that I mean
um if it's just we have to get the
language of supports right um we we
can't have every developer forking major
you know rust libraries or and let alone
Russ because Russ is the best the best
supported language right
um so you know when you get down to
python or or uh
you know or other languages that we you
know we have to have a good story we
can't have them say yeah you can use
Python but you can only you know go
within the main uh packages right so
yeah
I I'd also throw out just like core
Library support right and and sorting
out dependencies and dependency trees
and dependencies of dependencies uh
there's a talk I can't remember which
one is but like if anyone's ever seen a
dependency graph of like a real
microservice it looks like a firecracker
this is an explosion right it's like all
it takes is one thing not working in
wasm to blow that whole thing up
um the provider model where you can you
know basically go out to native code
communicate and distribute systems
fashion helps don't get me wrong but
also like we need more things running in
wasm natively
any other questions
all right then give it up again thank
you so much
[Applause]